here more with more on this breaking
news a big win for the president is the
president's attorney Jay Sekulow Jay
what he got well this is look this is
you just said John this is huge because
this was basically the DNC's trial of
the Russia hoax and they basically took
this whole wikileaks inquiry that went
on and tried to turn it into a federal
lawsuit and a judge appointed by bill
clinton that when he was president said
that the allegations are divorced from
the fact the evidence doesn't support
the allegation they also raised the
judge raised serious issues involving
the freedom of speech freedom of
association so what you have here is an
attempt by the Democratic National
Committee to litigate in federal court
allegations of Russia collusion Russia
conspiracy involving the Trump campaign
and not only is it protected by the
Department of Justice in the Muller
report but it's now rejected by a
federal court judge as I said appointed
by President Clinton who throws the case
out and says no evidence supporting any
of this and that the evidence was
divorced from the allegation nothing
that would back up what they asserted so
this is a very very significant win in
federal court a very significant win
through the president I think book this
was the death knell this is the end
point of this whole Russia hopes they
could win it on inclusion conspiracy
they could win on obstruction they could
win in civil court in a civil litigation
in federal court against the campaign
either here's what you have at the end
of the day as it started this was a hope
from the beginning and it saw through it
all right Jay Sekulow the attorney for
the president thank you sir